si sta giocando
il diamante non ci credo ce l'hai fatta
No Hahaha
salta Sofia avanti mi ha fregato il
diamante quello dietro di me non è
giocavano io no Benvenuti al solito
nuovissimo gioco Questa volta non
dobbiamo scegliere la porta sbagliata
nessuno è sopravvissuto Beh è già
iniziato praticamente che cosa succede
c'è qualcuno qui Vi ricordate il gioco
dell'ascensore in cui ogni piano
succedeva qualcosa di strano cioè c'era
un nuovo cattivo
granny Grey Panda Beh insomma ogni volta
c'era un nuovo cattivo questa volta ogni
porta ci sarà un nuovo ostacolo da
superare un nuovo luogo Ad esempio
adesso
sta arrivando si sta allagando tutto
quindi bisogna salire più in alto
possibile per sopravvivere Oh come non
detto ah ah perché non siamo
sopravvissuti a questa porta Quindi
dobbiamo cercare di sopravvivere a più
porte
sensibili e ogni volta sarà diverso
quello che dovremmo affrontare super
divertente
sono stati proprio bravissimi questa
volta siamo di nuovo sopra e adesso
mancano 10 porte fino al boss finale il
campo finale che dovremo affrontare
heheheh ovviamente lasciato un bel mi
piace qua perché se questo video
raggiunge i 5000 mi piace faremo una
seconda parte in cui dovremo scegliere
Anzi non scegliere le porte sbagliate
Cioè non riproveremo con nuove porte
allora eh qui è tutto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
molto strana questa porta Vabbè
vediamo la prossima porta devi comprare
la chiave del negozio per aprire il
Portello No mi dispiace Non puoi
scappare da sopra Ancora non ti sei
messo le mutande
Che figata
Ma questo è il paradiso per Vitale
stanno
piovendo Wow È tutto sì
che figo che c'entra Non lo so Quindi
non c'entra niente il più possibile
Comunque io con le gambette sono un
muffin con le gambette Mi piace troppo
Sì abbiamo tutti le gambe non so Ah hai
visto Hai visto questo topino di
cioccolato Qua sono in alto No non sono
riuscita a salire lì e aspetta un
momento perché sono rimasta un muffin Ma
perché la vita è più bella da muffin No
no no chi non è sopravvi
rimane muffin prossima porta siamo
tipo
che cosa succede al muffin nella piscina
Eh sì in breve si scioglie No io voglio
tornare negli Slime
sopravvissuto
mancano 7 porte fino al boss finale e io
sono ancora un muffin prossima porta
Preparati a saltare Okay okay non ho
fatto in tempo a saltare sono morta
subito Uh fa passare troppo difficile è
molto più difficile di quello
dell'ascensore prossima porta No vabbè
Questo gioco è assurdo ci sono no questo
tipo di come si chiamano delle foche che
ballano
il gioco non ha nessun senso
prossima volta siamo nello spazio aiuto
ci sono anche gli impostori Diamonds Wow
che bello Sto volando senza gravità Wow
bellissimo cosa devo fare però eh Dove
devo cadere dove devo nella navicella
Infatti ho fatto solo 12 punti
buttiamoci qua
Sì forse dobbiamo raggiungere quella
navicella No ho preso qualcuno
senza gravità due porte Apri la porta
sbrigati
Grazie
love Grazie
via prossima porta cosa ci aspetta
Adesso ci sono delle dei soldi banconote
bisogna saltare in questi soldi sì
perché non ha senso niente in questo
gioco
la cosa più bella di questo gioco È che
non ha senso
un orologio logico almeno nell'ascensore
c'era un filo logico e cioè bisognava
sconfiggere tutti i cattivi e c'erano
tutti i cattivi Qua invece tutte le
porte portano a un posto che non ha
senso sfracellato prossima porta
si corre Uh dai Vediamo se questa volta
riusciamo a sopravvivere non sono
sopravvissuta neanche una porta
possibile che sono così piatta sono
caduto nell'universo Io invece sto
dicendo posso Sì sì andiamo andiamo
andiamo andiamo
Uh no vabbè un giocatore ho già vinto
però almeno non sono morta è vero Io
sono qui ce la posso farcela Vediamo se
vediamo Vitale arrivare
cosa ci aspetteranno qualcuno dei
giocatori è stato trasformato in nuovo
fuoco
cosa è successo
È questo il boss finale
è un pirata
che cosa gli possiamo tirare addosso non
abbiamo niente Forse dobbiamo buttarli e
andare verso la sua nave vediamo No non
posso neanche buttarmi lì Ah lui sta
attenta lui sta tirando tipo delle delle
onde fotoniche Uh uh uh oh no forse
dobbiamo solo sopravvivere Ma lui ha la
vita è scomparso sta tirando delle bombe
Uffa ma cosa dobbiamo fare ok siamo
riusciti a sopravvivere aspetta
forse dobbiamo solo evitare quello che
ci sta mandando addosso
attento che ce l'hai dietro giapponese
Dov'è forse Bisogna andarli addosso così
Guarda No c'ho già provato
bisogna stare attenti a saltare quando
ti manda quelle quelle cose fotoniche
queste bombe Ah volevo dirti che io sono
un fantasma non posso aiutarvi
Sono trasparenti vediamo dove evitare
Aspetta dai dei mari ne è rimasta
soltanto un pezzo quindi cosa sta
facendo adesso
Non lo so ma è diventata notte
te la fate a sconfiggerlo sai della vita
allora ci sta lanciando addosso queste
luci Gialle curve Eh allora ci siamo
quasi forza eh Ah aiuto sta tirando però
ci siamo quasi dobbiamo solo
sopravvivere credo
Oh ce l'abbiamo fatta
Sì è stata colpita
[Applauso]
vediamo la classifica Eh io sono 14
punti Wow
vediamo cosa ci aspetta nella prossima
ora ok guarda sono tutti appiccicati qua
perché non vedo l'ora di entrare È tutto
buio c'è solo un lampione Eh io continuo
ad andare avanti
Siamo arrivati Ah bisogna salire sul
lampione
Corri corri c'è scritto così no
[Musica]
Chi è il cattivo non lo vedo
scuro Vabbè io scappo Mi sembra mi
sembra quella del dentista che ti
inseguiva quel cane con quel cane coi
denti tutto di ferro staremo andando
dalla parte giusta subito c'è un quadro
orribile mamma chi apparirà adesso
Ok Qui c'è un quadro di aiuto no un
altro quadro pensavo fosse un'uscita e
credo che stiamo andando dalla parte
giusta Dai non credo speriamo non ci
credo siamo sopravvissuti eh eh È vero
forse finalmente stiamo riuscendo a
capire come funziona
vivere Ah l'orologio ti dice quanto
tempo passa Perché non si apre la
prossima volta dove siamo noi
la camera bambino allora dice dobbiamo
stare nel colore nero
vedi gli altri colori sono spariti
Ok adesso e adesso tira un altro colore
dobbiamo stare attenti
e mi Stavi spostando
siamo sopravvissuti ancora Ok adesso
vediamo il prossimo colore
rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa rosa
rosa rosa rosa
strano è sopravvissuto me lo chiedo
anch'io infatti come ho fatto prossimo
colore
anche questa torta prima l'orologio
Quanto manca quando l'orologio arriva a
mezzogiorno
Quindi alla prossima volta
quando l'orologio arriva al mezzogiorno
[Musica]
Ok siamo in salvo
si sta allagando tutto ma noi siamo qua
sopra
È vero sembra
cosa cosa
Aspetta non è giusto
Uffa mancano molto stage al boss finale
penso che sia un boss diverso ogni volta
ok Eccoci qua
[Musica]
sopra la scala sopra la scala
io salgo qui
C'è qualcuno
quasi
bravo Tu sei salito sopra l'armadio
tutto bene questa cioccolata
c'è già un giocatore davanti a me va
devo riuscire a superarlo bisogna
prendere il premio e arrivare prima
ci sono quasi lo sto quasi per superare
veramente eh Non ci credo
Uffa Non ce l'ho fatta a superare questa
paura prossimo
Sono salito qui ok sono sulla scala
quel giocatore senza bruciacchiando non
me ne frega niente
un po' di calore ogni tanto
Oh no mi sono bruciata
Ma pure io sono bruciacchiato o sbaglio
siamo brucia
ti
Preparati a combattere contro chi
è il nemico non lo vedo dov'è la spada
Ah che bello almeno abbiamo qualcosa per
combattere questa volta
il nemico Non lo so qualcuno è stato
sfracellato
dobbiamo combattere l'unico contro gli
altri
Oh no forse è vero hai ragione perché
quel giocatore è appena sfracellato
l'altro Che cattivo Molto bene
Ma insomma L'ultimo sopravvissuto Eh Hai
vinto davvero ancora uno non l'avevo
vista era rimasto immobile lì Vediamo
chi vincerà tra voi due Non ci posso
credere che invitare mi ha sfracellato
Beh Chi ha vinto Boh non lo so siamo
sopravvissuti tutti e due mi sa che hai
fatto un sacco di punti Vittoria se lo
puoi fare Grazie Ah prossima porta Siamo
in un bar
e ovviamente Vitale verrà raggruppato
dal cibo ma aspetta un po' di strano
Eh non fa entrare nel bar perché forse
un'altra delle stranezze di quello
grande vedi Ah dobbiamo guardare lo show
Sì forse stasera
[Musica]
una bambolina Malefica rispostati Non ti
far prendere
Ah possiamo entrare
molto facile
Ah Ho cambiato programma in TV
che figo
Chi è Oh siamo nella cameretta di
qualcuno che sta giocando ai videogiochi
del videogioco fortnite
non si può uscire dalla finestra questo
forse è il creatore del videogioco
però non ci fa niente Comunque
sopravviveremo sicuramente
c'era qualcuno che stava gridando
Ahó 150 milioni di iscritti mi sembra
quello che bello questo gattino che sta
suonando i tamburo
un terremoto no No la casa si sta
girando si sta girando la cassa dove
sono aiutami
ma è fighissimo Stiamo al contrario
Adesso vedi io sto camminando sul
soffitto capito che figo eh No si sta
girando nuovamente Cerchiamo di non
sfracellarsi e non morire Sono caduta Ah
sono ancora vivo
Io ho 22 punti e tu 16 però c'è anche
una corona che non so quanto vale ma
vedo la corona
qua è tornato con il gattino dove siamo
figo come fare è capitato anche prima Ma
è difficilissimo
saltiamo subito in alto No ho cancellato
anch'io
per un pelo
okay okay okay
è arrivato uno già devo riuscire a
raggiungere almeno voglio vedere cosa
c'è dentro la navicella
manca pochissimo non mi dire che adesso
scade è scaduto
mi sa che c'è il boss finale adesso
perché dice Zero chi è non è più il
pirata
Chi sarà sono nob nob il dio di questo
mondo Ok Benvenuti in giro chiaro
il LEGO di fuoco non vi mostrerò Nessuna
pietà
sono rinata come hai fatto io non riesco
a vederlo trasportato bravo
sfracellato quasi tutti Non so se questa
volta riusciremo a sconfiggere il boss
finale Ok adesso rimandrà rimanderà di
nuovo con laser di fuoco Eccolo
siete morti tutti
sono un giocatore non vinceremo mai
questa volta solo due giocatori
Avete vinto
Avete vinto la battaglia ma non la
guerra Si incontreremo di nuovo e non
sarete così fortunati Wow grazie a due
giocatori che sono rimasti in vita
abbiamo dovuto anche questo boss Uhm
andiamo tornati qua allora questa volta
non mi freghi so che devo salire in un
posto più alto altrimenti rimarremo
comunque nell'acqua Allora io sono
salito qui però forse si può salire
ancora più in su
Ok io sono salita in questa sorta di
Torre però poi bisogna andare ancora più
in alto l'acqua è arrivata sta arrivando
l'albero
penso che qua sopra non arrivi tu dove
sei avvocato no dove risalito Sei una
torre di ferro arrugginito Ecco Te l'ho
detto prima siamo arrivati intrappolati
io vedo gli altri giocatori là nella
casetta Uh ho fatto un sacco di punti
sono 23 punti adesso No di nuovo questa
volta arriverò nella navicella questa
volta ci arriverò perché sono arrivate
Uh che era saltiamo Qua sembra facile
Ah ok ogni volta che Vitale dice Sì
posso farcela muore no no ce l'ho fatta
questa volta e adesso verso la navicella
e oltre
[Musica]
Ah
lo sai che forza c'è una buona
possibilità che riesco ad arrivarci
come ho detto niente
Non è giusto sono vicinissimo
soprattutto
Eccoli
Ehi non fare del male a nessuno dei miei
amici hanno eliminato uno e ora
eliminiamo anche questa via via via
Ah ecco
questo giocatore Sta colpendo l'altro il
giocatore
così ci sono gli altri che stanno
navigando Quindi tu ti sei nascosto
Google Translate
è vivo prossima porta che c'è in TV oggi
c'è
un gatto nero
rosso
ABC dobbiamo scegliere il pulsante
indovinare tutte e tre le domande e ci
proviamo dai la risposta giusta o muori
Okay quali sono le domande vediamo qual
è il pianeta più grande Marte
Giove o Saturno
Beh era giusto o sbagliato
siamo sopravvissuti Sì quindi forse era
giusto E qual è l'altra domanda Qual è
il continente più grande Africa Europa
Asia presto presto
Ultima domanda
lì
gli unici due sopravvissuti Quanto ci
vuole pochissimo
ok
gli unici due sopravvissuti Che bello
Quanti punti abbiamo Sì
ye ye ye
8 ancora si sta per aprire una porta Ok
di nuovo Oh no odio questo ansia
Cambiati vedi sono diversi
sì oh Fatemi salire Fatemi salire
No sta salendo sta salendo l'acqua Ehi
ma sei caduto
Sì non sono riuscito a salire
Mmm Stai attenta devo andare su guarda
la luce dai salta eh Uh Brava vediamo Se
l'acqua arriva fino a qua
siamo nel posto più alto mi sembra di sì
Wow
brava ce l'hai fatta
in classifica 27 punti Wow
in classifica in genere
profumata Uh uh uh vero Wow Non ci credo
raga
è la prima volta che succede che sono
prima Ehi dovresti fare tipo per me no
eh no io faccio tipo per me hahaha
credi di arrivare primo uh uh Diamante
non ci credo ce l'hai fatta No no no no
non ci credo
più avanti mi ha fregato il diamante
quello dietro di me non è giusto
No no no no
come sempre Ah dice che un giocatore è
arrivato per primo ma tu dici
oh no adesso non tornerò normale rimarrò
sempre un baffi
uguali siamo tutti i baffi da adesso
manca solo una porta fino al boss finale
tutto buio Cos'è Super Mario attento Mi
sa che spara adesso qualche ragionata
le banane forse
che sta succedendo perché sta sparando
delle feste di Mario No vabbè non si
vede più niente
Non ci siamo sopravvissuti ancora
non si capisce niente Wow sono
sopravvissuto
Oh l'ultimo l'ultimo boss finale pronti
uno diverso Uffa ma io sono un muffin
come è andata a vincere il pirata da
baffin Dai che sta lanciando le sue
mezzelune cosmiche
Sarebbe bello tirargli i muffin in testa
Ma io continuo a saltare poi sarebbe
bello anche che queste bombe che tira
queste palle di cannone che ci tira
addosso sei rimbalzasse
rimbalzassero sul muffin tipo
Sì in effetti sarebbe bello sarebbe
bello colpirlo in qualche modo anche
diciamo sarebbe bello anche mangiare il
muffin Oh sì che bello
Qual è il tuo gusto preferito del muffin
quello con
il mirtillo te l'ho detto metto
cioccolato Guarda a me piace tipo Questo
qui vedi bianco
sopra
mi piace anche quello tutto al
cioccolato però effettivamente mi piace
anche quello dei mirtilli Oppure quello
bianco col cioccolato dentro oppure
prendo il cioccolato fondente al
cioccolato bianco dentro il ghiaccio il
cioccolato Chissà che mi piacciono anche
tutti i muffin Hahaha parola segreta del
giorno se avete visto il video fino a
qua scrivete nei commenti ma fino al
cioccolato vediamo visto il video fino
alla fine ok
sconfitto
[Musica]
20 Ah abbiamo vinto anche se siamo dei
muffin gioco completato
i morti nessuno
Può cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quello che preferite
eh Buona visione Ciao